a mugging the most dangerous man in this
entire neighborhood is bobby lee
that's definitely the truth i can see
that yeah okay i'm
very dangerous not physically but just
in my mind
i can implant things in your mind yeah
interest thank you so much like he will
burn our own house down cleveland what
happened recently
oh well that wasn't really his fault
my god you guys have you
ever thought about like you know when
you worry about your
own death what are things that pop in
your head like is it
would you die from a plane crash or do
you die from a sickness like what are
things that
cross your mind oh gilb sorry about that
i don't know why that's on
i want to be death by churro like
choking on a churro
is that what you think about no be real
no but like working at a churro factory
and then like something a mishap
happening and like 90 000 churros just
landing on top of me and i just drowned
in it okay so
when they see my body though i'll have a
smile on my face stampede by churro
i love terrell okay so what i'm what
you're saying is you have final
destination thoughts i don't
i always i always like my worries are
always
like either medical or my my biggest one
is car accident
or even though like i'm a swimmer you
always never not think about
drowning and stuff right what never
occurred to me was that i could
potentially
have a crushing injury or a crushing
death
by refrigerator you know
no fear i didn't ever occur to me and it
almost happened to me
uh two nights ago she bro
i witnessed it okay number one
i realized that i'm a coward
that i don't have really good reflexes
right and that whatever happens to
kalila if she dies in front of my eyes
reflex base it'll it'll be reflux-based
reflex face
it'll be it'll be like she she died in
front of me
and they're like did you stop the bullet
nothing
okay so you know yeah so you know how um
bobby flooded the home right
okay bobby aka the cat flooded the home
right
and so for the last two weeks we've had
construction workers
um basically rip out our floors and try
to dry the floor underneath it
so they've had to um our fridge is
normally
bolted onto the wall and so to get
to the floor underneath the fridge
they've had to unbolt the fridge
and move it to the living space so
there's just a freestanding fridge right
in the middle of our living room
right and um i
um jules and i picked up the groceries
and brought it upstairs to put it away
in the fridge
and as i was putting stuff away in the
fridge
i guess the fridge was on a slight tilt
forward
and all the doors opened up where was
bobby
he was actually sitting in the living
room like watching this whole thing
happen no i was
no spectating tell me your version okay
first of all
my version is this okay i have no idea
what the [ __ ] you guys are doing
we're putting groceries away i
understand that right but i hear
people lifting things and like opening
packages whatever right yeah
my attention is i'm watching picard
the cbs show yeah i'm not watching no
i'm watching star trek the next
generation
it's the episode where the card falls in
love with nella nella
okay and so i love love stories you're
in it you're
as you know i love love stories yeah as
you know i love picard
you hate when picard falls in love i
don't i turn away from the kissing sands
whenever he tries to kiss her i just go
what the [ __ ]
right like turn away why is that because
he's the captain and he you don't you
don't kiss
when you're the captain you just
everyone deserves love i know when you
think about it though
you know because they don't show this in
the tv show but if that was real
yeah he must masturbate oh for sure yeah
of course yeah but
imagine picard you know what i mean
where do you think earl grey tea
before bed and then he plays his little
flute secures his keypad so no one can
open this right yeah
yeah and then he probably pulls his
pants down
and he goes engage and just
make it so
right where do you think he splooges oh
[ __ ] probably right it probably split
just right under that little
symbol on the badge yeah on the page
right or maybe it's blue just right
because they have these little um these
little things on their neck that shows
them the ranking
oh yeah yeah anyway so you can play
socks on the enterprise
i don't [ __ ] know i've never thought
you're a super fan i never
do they wear i don't know i don't would
they need socks i make assumptions that
they make
i've never looked at like worth shoes or
anything like that
i'm saying so picard is not a sploogen
socks kind of guy
no there's no way i think that um who
does their laundry
he has bob answer all these that's
interesting i never thought of that
is it a korean there's so many things
i've never thought of i've never thought
of
if they wear socks if they how do they
do their laundry masturbation yeah
but um i i assume that those things
happen they must i've seen them drink
and
eat food and whatnot but anyway okay
sorry so i'm watching um
picard fall in love on the show yeah
and all of a sudden a hero
and i look to my left and the [ __ ]
refrigerator is landing on kalila's head
this gigantic metal refrigerator and she
shoulder chucks it
all of the food and the jars like the
glass things broke on top of my body at
this point are you wonder woman
like shoulder so what i did and i'm
gonna say this
i'm gonna have to give a shout out i
know people hate group workouts but i'm
going to give a shout out
to barry's boot camp shout out to barry
because ask bobby it turns out i have
superhuman strength
and i didn't say a word when it was
happening i basically just lifted the
fridge
yeah and juliana was frozen
trying to help me but she couldn't
because of the angle and this fridge was
all
halfway like already how much was the
already at this point was it
it was over basically all the weight of
the [ __ ] refrigerator is on her
shoulder by the way
it was like this already that far yeah
the fridge just
fell like straight over it imagine a
tree falling over that's
all the glass and everything was
crashing on my head and everything and i
basically just had to
dead lift it and push it back this way
okay so that is scary so okay that
happens you're
first of all you're watching a love
story so you're thank you i'm watching
pop
papa love his love story you see that
fall on and i
i see it fall i go what do i say what's
the first thing yeah
all i hear is because i have i have to
basically do a deep squat right to pull
the fridge off of me
all i could hear for 30 seconds
you're like i know that's awesome i i i
i'll argue that timeline
and he i was like can somebody [ __ ]
help me no not 30 seconds i argue that
you know i gotta give it up to jules
though she tried so
hard with her little legs she's a twig
she's a twig i think she made it worse
she made it fall more yeah yeah because
she had her little [ __ ] arm on the
thing
and she's in complete [ __ ]
shock so i i get up
and i start pushing you know i mean the
the door handle meanwhile there's kimchi
there's mustard all over the floor old
salsa old burrito
everything that was in the everything
was just scattered all over the thing
the dogs were freaking out it was a
[ __ ] mayhem
it was our own 911. your own falling
tower
yeah it was our own 911 and so we
finally get it
into place and um we all had just
that moment of like holy [ __ ]
kalila almost died by refrigerator
by refrigerator and then and then the
cops the cops what
no if they did oh what happened
the fridge fell on her head really what
happens
but i swear to god i was watching it
that you know you like next generation
i would say that like love stories you
love you like love stories
you know what he said afterwards because
he didn't want to go what did you say
were you pissed at this point or were
you kind of just like in disbelief
eventually after about i it felt like 30
seconds he says 15 seconds eventually
he helps me do the final push on the
fridge
thank you he got there so like the last
five percent of my
leg strength he he helped with but he
got there i got i got there
and then but he didn't want to help
clean up the mess
so his thing was i will not he told me
and jules he's like i'm going to give
you two weeks break
of no booger attacks oh wow if you
clean all of it up and jules and i took
the deal you got to take that we hate
i thought it was like once in a while
you got it wait the booger
yeah i was like hey once a week maybe
can i just can i just he he has a whole
wall of boogers and he peels it's not a
wallah bugger it's a napkin follower
it's like you know how people have
sticker collections
is that waxy paper i love anything that
sticks yeah yeah he has a whole booklet
of boogers and like like a sticker
collection and then he just chooses
which
booger to peel out of that i'm a
disgusting thing and then he
puts it on us so um can i just defend
myself real quick
is let's say george george let's say you
and i were hiking
never will never will happen but let's
suppose
and out of the sky a [ __ ] piano
is falling a full-blown grand piano is
falling towards your head
right my first initial reaction
is gonna be able to process right
is that a piano right i mean you because
you would
you had you would have to check your
mind and your eyes
to see if they're connected yeah and
then you have to [ __ ]
so when the refrigerator is falling on
her that's what i'm going through baby
like what the [ __ ] is this going on i'm
processing
what's going on because it's never
happened before i didn't think it would
it could ever happen right so that's
what that 10 seconds is
you know to i will i will agree with you
in the sense that while it was happening
and
everything was falling on my body i
thought
is this a refrigerator attacking
yeah yes see that's what i'm saying i
didn't make sense to me too like my
instinct was just to push back right and
to lift the the freezer handle like
away um but i i
you're right i don't think i maybe would
have moved as fast
either to help you if it happens thank
you thank you so it was
it was a bizarre wow yeah incident i'm
just so
you know i have these like um flashbacks
enough i have this fear that what if it
was jules
and she's like so much smaller than me
and she's a strong girl but she is
you know what i mean these are
physically different though she weighs
on 90 pounds
she would have [ __ ] died she weighs
90 pounds but imagine that phone call to
the philippines like to her mom like hey
yeah yeah you know we have a gigantic
metal refrigerator
what is that what is that
yeah incidentally i just want to say
that um
i'll forget it something doesn't mean
anything it means everything tell me
yeah imagine we live in a world now
where
you know you ca you can videotape at any
moment
you know you can you know the world is
connected that way
you can't really you know imagine trying
to murder somebody it'd be very
difficult right but my point is is that
um like
we get videos of like karen's right